this was uh huge breaking news yesterday
lee zeldin a republican from new york
someone tried to stab him and they're
saying it was an alleged stabbing and
i'm like there's a picture of the guy
holding
i don't know what it's called but it's
got two blades on it in his hand as he's
like going and then zeldan's holding his
arm back you watch the video first the
guy didn't run full speed and jump up he
casually gets up walks up and goes like
this and then gets his arm grabbed
almost like he didn't really want to do
it but i'm not going to say that
he went for it and got taken you know
pulled down thrown down
this dude got released immediately
mm-hmm which leaves zeldan predicted
that night but we're we're talking about
a man
who attempted to assassinate at by at
the at minimum
attempted to stab in the neck a a a
republican running for governor and they
just caught him loose right away how is
it how i thought that only happens in
the uk that's new york state law it's
interesting because lee zeldin one of
his major platforms running he's
challenging kathy hogel is
that the crime laws in uh in in new york
are terrible and that they don't keep
people safe who need to be kept safe so
it's just irony of irony that he was
like i can tell you he said this at 1 30
in the morning like under new york state
law this man will be released and he was
completely right because he knows the
law they charged him with attempted
second-degree assault you jump on stage
to a sitting member of congress
when a senior member of congress is
there with a blade in your hand and go
for his neck and that that's it
i'm i i
i've heard some like arguments that he
was actually reaching for the the
microphone and that the blade
because the governor uh um zeldan said
that he said you're done to him before
he came at him maybe he was going to try
and grab the mic why does he have a
weapon in his hand see if you're
approaching a guy with a weapon it
doesn't make any sense attempted murder
i've heard other people say oh well
those are like self-defense key chains
they're not that serious but it's like
why would we sell them to women for
self-defense that's what they are if
you're attacked at night they want you
to be able to hit your attacker and have
more force i mean it's it's a very
strange thing to do and it is even
stranger to me that he's just on the
show do you have a picture of the blade
yep yeah let me see if i can pull it up
on twitter this is wild i'm not uh i'm
not gonna provide a defense for a guy
who jumped on stage
holding a blade and going after a
sitting member of congress and telling
him he's done that allegedly i don't
know
yeah so it's uh like
who knows what that is is that i don't
know what it's called people probably
know what it's called it's got two
spikes on it you hold it between your
fingers they're self-defense key chains
yeah yeah yeah and in the in the video
you can see his arm go up and around
towards the neck and that's what a lot
of people reported that he took a swing
at his neck at zeldin's neck and then
they grabbed his arm and then someone
bear hugged him and pinned him down
you jump on stage wielding a weapon
saying you're done
and then move your arm around with the
blade in it like dude come on
um is there a video of it of the attack
i guess we'll call it an attack there
are some flying along yeah you can't you
can't see that much but you can you can
look it up it's it's a little far away
but you can see him reach for it i just
think regardless this is uh here's what
i think of this guy i did some digging
into his into his background and his
family and stuff trying to find out what
i could about him
i don't know a whole lot
um and this is based on some of his
family but it seems like their default
democrat types like naive ignorant not
really paying attention
my my personal assumption is that this
guy is probably a dude who watches msnbc
and cnn
hears the rhetoric here's what hulk says
about zeldin being a big lie trump
insurrectionist type and so he's like i
better do something about this you know
it's like so he so he goes out there
thinking he's going to stop this guy
radicalization this is what i wrote
about in the newsweek article about
january 6. the reason raskin included me
out of context in his video is to drive
escalation
they so already we have had people uh
people i work with people who work for
me and and people i know say
they've they saw like the reason that
the newsweek article came to be is
because i got hit up by newsweek and
they said the moment we saw you in that
clip we knew it was like like
something's not right here and they're
like you want to write about this and
there were a bunch of people hit me up
and said like my family saw that and
they were like whoa that's the guy you
watch and had to explain to them that it
was fake that they're lying about this
but it's radicalizing people well this
is the point i made earlier if you
remember when we started with bannon
it's like this worries me because your
country is being radicalized against
itself it's and the two sides are being
encouraged to see each other's enemies
you talk about it in war-like terms it's
a war we have to destroy them and this
is what you end up with people going on
stage trying to stab politicians
although i tell you uh there there are
people on the right who are certainly
saying stuff about like the tree of
liberty and things like that the people
on the left are uh
you you have the establishment left
which is the democratic they're the ones
calling for
conflict they're the ones saying like
arrest them shut them down take away
their votes and then you have the
leftists the socialists who just they've
always won a revolution anyway so
they're like bring it on
then you have the you know more fringe
elements of the of the right side that
are saying tree of liberty and crazy
stuff like that but then when you look
at the prominent
right and and middle which is unified
it's totally opposed to all the conflict
and violence so i think the the main
issue is
what do we talk about when we talk about
uh the civil war whatever it's usually
like a national divorce can it be
peaceful and how do we prepare for it to
protect ourselves against attacks not to
attack you look at the left and they're
talking about how to go and arrest
people and shut them and and they're
they're mocking bannon they're wielding
the power of the federal government uh
against the previous administration they
are wielding law enforcement power to
destroy their enemies my worry is though
tim is if you think about this story
right if that politician is a republican
right if he gets stabbed that will
radicalize people on the right as well
and this is the process right you go
from one to another to another and
before you know everyone wants to kill
you but but maybe radical radicalize
isn't the right word if we i mean we
literally just saw someone tried to
assassinate brett kavanaugh
these leftist groups
broke the law
and the ag did nothing about it and
everybody asked them like hey you know
this was illegal and he's like don't
care then someone then i i said this if
you do not uphold the law when it comes
to protesting at this home they will
escalate of course and the next step was
the guy showed up with the crowbar and
the rope and the taser or whatever he
had pepper spray really is like a fire
if you don't put it out it just keeps
growing if you don't enforce the law
equally for both sides you have no law
right right so here's what i'm gonna say
it's not radicalization when when we
just had two assassination attempts in
the span of like a month or so for for
someone on the right to be like i better
bring a gun with me it's not a
radicalization it's not them saying they
want to kill someone it's them saying i
don't want to be killed i watch the
video i uh i don't think he's trying to
kill him he walked up to him and then he
started talking to him and actually
backed away like a half a foot and then
started to grab at him so it was an
assault but he would have walked up the
blade in his hand yeah he like walked up
and started talking to him why does he
need to become go armed and the other
thing to tim's point is that see his arm
go around for the neck uh they struggled
yeah
he lifted him up if he wanted to kill
him he would have walked up and killed
him that's not true you don't walk up
and start talking to someone if you want
you are wrong in fact the most effective
way to to do it is to do it slowly uh
not on stage and running at someone
immediately gets you tackled oh yeah his
approach for sure but once he stood got
up to him he just stood there and
started talking to him
and then they struggled i'm not gonna
say i know what he was thinking but he
had a blade in his hand and he motioned
for his neck and people often make these
mistakes because they base their views
on movies in a movie you see the guy
jump up and ah i'm to get you when you
look in real life assassinations could
be very very simple and
i'll tell you i'll tell you about uh i
was you ever see those theaters those
theater events where they have the ninja
and uh actually it's a better example
i'll start this way you ever see those
those comedy routines where there's a
black a black background on a stage and
then the guy will get fake slashed and
then his body splits because it's
actually two people wearing you know a
white white pants and a white shirt but
then they're wearing all black the the
idea of why ninja wear all black was
because they would do plays
and to make the ninja
not be able to be seen on stage she
would wear all black against a black
backdrop then when they popped out and
did something oh it was a ninja in
reality ninja would dress like a farmer
if you want to infiltrate to assassinate
someone you have to blend in not wear
all black they would do other tricks too
and they would calmly approach not
psychotically run up full speed and
scream
they'd walk up very calmly and smile and
waving so what you're saying is this
guy's a ninja what i'm saying is
that
that right there you cannot determine
whether it was an assassination attempt
because he walked slowly or not it's
true in fact i think walking slowly is
is more
is yeah but if the guy like walks up to
you with that thing on his hand in the
street
you'd be worried right for sure if
someone approaches me on the street i'm
worried but right right
i'm ready to run
you're on stage and when this guy gets
up and walks over he's wearing a veteran
hat they're thinking like what's
happening i'll tell you another story
famous story uh or i should say it may
be apocryphal urban legend
a security guard was in a bank three
guys walk in with with ski masks on and
rifles and and they just walk right up
to him and say drop your gun and he goes
oh he drops it and then they rob the
bank and after they asked the security
guard why didn't you do anything and he
was like i couldn't believe it was
actually happening like i don't know
they was they just walked up to me and
just took my gun you wanna play have you
wanna play this clip zelda oh we can't
we can't play an assassination attempt
on youtube that's what you're saying
zelda addressed it and he said like i
could see this guy coming out of the
corner of my eye like i could see they
had he had a hat on that maybe had a
veterans thing but like when this is
happening
you can't really
stop to be like oh i'm gonna reason with
him like you just have to deal with
what's going on like grabbed his wrists
things like that i will also note that
the hocal campaign specifically called
out this event in an email saying like
it's it's a mega republican bus tour
that big line lee is like like they drew
attention to this event they radicalized
people and then pointed them in this
direction yeah because that's the big i
mean we are a very divided country and
especially in new york you see it as uh
hoco lining up behind a lot of the more
liberal policies that new york has
carried through the pandemic and then
zeldin is an a vocal trump supporter so
they are a perfect contrast and to have
this become something that's happening
in their state and then for him to
correctly call out that the guy who
attacked him is going to be released
like it doesn't look great but they're
not really looking for a mediation
between these two sides who got hulkel
put put there like she was lieutenant
governor under cuomo and then cuomo
resigned she took over so she's running
to be elected she was she assumed the
the spot afterwards
didn't cuomo want to run again or
something i think so yeah he's like i'm
gonna come here he's never gonna i'm
gonna run it into the ground this time
yeah but i think this this is the stuff
i've been talking about and it's funny
because you know i'll say something like
i think we're headed towards a civil war
and four years ago people said that was
stupid and then i was a [ __ ] and then i
was like bro i don't know i just read
the atlantic and they were like we
talked to security experts who said the
united states is headed for civil war
we're in a fifth generational world war
right now and we noir yes see the other
day you were arguing that it wasn't now
you're saying it's not i'm very commit
convinced we're in a fifth generational
war meaning it's a cyber war a war of
the mind and the spirit and it is global
it's corporations in all countries
making you think it's from another
country it's 14 year olds in their
parents bedroom in the middle of
wherever they live uh and it's everybody
is is not everybody but it is a lot of
people vying for power uh digitally in
in the cyber space
and they want they would love to see the
united states shoot itself but um you
know how do you comment a lot of people
would better
better better thoughts ideas
communication skills better emotions
staying calm i don't know if there's a
there's a way to solve it it's i think
there's
it may end up being some kind of
natural selection phenomenon where those
that are have the the perspicacity to
see what's happening start preparing for
the winter and those that don't will
starve in the winter you know what i
mean i think it's it's more of a common
threat issue if you guys felt that you
like if an alien invasion happened
suddenly we'd stop all this [ __ ]
fighting wouldn't we right no i i don't
know
either i think we'd give some people to
the aliens we had a pandemic
yeah and
that did not stop it
in the uk it did for about three weeks
and then when we we backed went back to
the culture war but it did i think a
genuine uh yeah if aliens came you'd
have the left being like we need to
accept diversity right being like
they're literally invading and they'd be
like you don't know that they're
bringing us technology what if the
aliens are transphobic maybe not thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there